so the u.s. midterm elections are coming
up fast and the results can have a huge
impact on the final two years of
President Donald Trump's current term in
office and if you're wondering what the
hell midterm elections are don't worry
because I'm about to let you know in 60
seconds right after I eat this Carolina
Reaper oh my god
basically midterm elections take place
as it applies at the halfway point
between presidential elections and a
federal elections during which members
of Congress are selected by voters this
includes all 435 members of the US House
of Representatives
and one-third of US senators this year
Democrats were to win the house they'd
be able to they will be able to no God
oh I can't do it I'm gonna do the full
monologue one time clean I need to get
make sure I get these takes because
afterwards I won't be able to clean take
basically midterm elections take place
as the name implies at the halfway point
between presidential elections and our
federal elections during which members
of Congress are selected by voters this
includes all 435 members of the US House
of Representatives and one-third of US
senators you might be wondering what's
so important because maybe this isn't
quite as jazzy sounding as presidential
elections but no these elections are
incredibly important because the results
will dictate whether the democratic or
republican party will control each
chamber of Congress whichever party
controls each chamber will have an
easier time passing proposed legislation
in their chamber this year Democrats
were to win the house they will be able
to decide which bills come to the floor
control committee chairmanships and
support oversight investigation of
trumps administration if Republicans
maintain the Senate they'll be able to
appoint conservative judges and approve
Trump's cabinet nominees so regardless
of where you think politically get out
there and exercise your right to vote
this is the time to make your voice
heard
[Music]
jack is burning yeah it hurts this is
where I die